talking heads in the media were simply
amazed by joe biden's speech last night
listen
it was a very strong speech delivered
well started well ended well you could
just hear the thundering applause it was
a fairly solid performance i think this
is a reminder of why people elected joe
biden i thought that was joe biden at
his best
uncle joe is back
these are people who are paid to praise
biden but we wanted to hear what people
who aren't getting paid to praise him
thanks so
we spoke to real people
big speech last night what you think
um it was a good speech
i think so
do you know what speech i'm talking
about no it was great i enjoyed it a lot
what speech do you think i'm talking
about
uh
i don't know the state of the union
oh really yeah oh [ __ ] yeah crazy stuff
going on do you know who delivers the
state of the union no president biden
oh really he's a hypocrite all talk no
action a lot of mumbling it was
horrible president biden says the state
of the union is strong what do you think
i think it's extremely weak it's not
well i don't see it people are still
starving i don't think he's proven
himself yet inflation is at an all-time
high
our gas prices are extremely high we
need to bring back some of the old some
of the old trump policies and we'll see
how strong things really get president
biden says that he gets that inflation
hurts
do you think he gets it
no he is a man of money and power
inflation doesn't hurt him probably
doesn't affect his bank account too much
especially with all that money his
family has in ukraine he lives sort of
in a bubble and a cloud in the sky and
isn't here in the streets with us he
goes back to his little rich house and
he's got money so he doesn't really care
about the poor
or anybody president biden
says that
everything should be made in the united
states stamping products made in america
do you think we should be buying russian
oil
oh hell no no we have more than enough
oil in the united states they should
open the pipeline we probably go to war
with them why would we buy stuff from
them we buy the oil the money changes
hands
russian uh putin has money
and now he invades ukraine with that
same money aren't we supporting the
russian war at the end of biden's speech
last night he said
go get him
go get him
who is he talking about he's talking
about i would think on the short term
the russians probably the russians and
the russians he's definitely saying that
you know we should start coming for
russia's neck trump whoever he wants to
sniff next
i don't even know if he knows that he
ain't gonna get nobody president biden
first year in office what grade would
you give him
c a c
c minus c minus by d
d a good strong d a good strong d yeah
he's about an e well there's no e no e
so i think we're going to make an e
specifically just for this example f
epic failure joe biden thank you for
your words
but it's time for you to act more like
president zielinski
[Music]
wow joining me now to break it down
kellyanne conway former counselor to the
president
that is in
midtown manhattan that is not
the deep red south kellyanne
i that's no good that is no good your
thoughts jesse you would get that
reaction no matter where you are you'd
get that from the democrats in congress
not one but two of them actually had
responses to their own party leader
state of the union and you can forgive
the people that you talk to in midtown
manhattan they probably think joe biden
is the mayor of wilmington it's where he
spends most of his time
uh they saw last night a president miss
an opportunity every president has a
tremendous opportunity the state of
union to do a couple of things joe biden
did none of them
project strength build confidence
defy your critics and upend your
naysayers by really fooling them by
delivering a really great performance
that's against what they usually think
of you and trump did that all president
trump did that all four years i remember
after his first joint session of
congress which is what it's called the
first year and not the state of the
union that was the everybody said oh
where is this trump in my goodness
he's so measured he was so funny he was
so serious well that's what the voters
had seen all along but you know with
biden last night it was almost like he
was checking a box it was almost like he
was lancing a boil smoothing out a bump
it was just somewhere he had to be
that night on the schedule instead of
really projecting strength and optimism
the other thing that is confounding to
me and i think if this weren't so you
would have heard differently from the
people you interviewed today jesse
they really did not do what presidents
and first ladies do with the guest box
yeah i mean you have to show guests uh
you know people from d-day
elevating a tuskegee airman to brigadier
general a woman who had overcome her
drug addiction being reunited for the
first time with her baby the military
family being united the north korean
dissident coming on his crutches that he
used to escape korea in 2006 so it just
goes on and on and we didn't see much of
that at all we saw two bored women
behind joe biden and joe biden boring us
you're so right they could have put on a
russian dissident they could have put on
a world war ii veteran
who who fought the russians in eastern
europe they could have put on a coveted
nurse
they could have put on a little kid who
doesn't have to wear a mask in school
anymore
you're so right they could have done so
many things that that would have really
galvanized the country and he just he
just swung and he missed it's almost
like he didn't even swing it's like he
didn't even try
kellyanne it's it's the time to showcase
everyday heroes and it's also the time i
believe to announce new policies all he
did was deliver all he did was make new
promises and also you know don't don't
blame joe biden most presidents get up
there and they talk about their
accomplishments he really doesn't have
any and i don't say that as a partisan i
say that in all sincerity this is a guy
who has no energy policy and this is a
guy who has no energy at all
so it was a double whammy for him last
night i don't know what nancy pelosi was
doing with that odd standing up
uh grinding her teeth
doing this with that but it is the last
time we'll see her in the speaker's
chair that i guarantee you last time yes
that is actually that was the best
moment because it is the last time we
will see her there thank you very much
kellyanne conway as always great ideas
thank you jesse you could have used them
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else